If you're always in the spotlight, how do you make room for someone else?
You know, Hamilton goes his own way.
Does he have a comfort zone?
I see your point, but is the No. 1 racing driver only looking after himself?
Alicia Keys is always busy, but how can she stay in touch with her loved ones?
Hey ma.
Hi baby.
Hi, how are you doing?
I'm doing good.
Good, we're just on our way back from the beach.
And I have to tell you, as a professional athlete, you cannot stay up late nights.
If everyone knows you, where can you really feel safe?
Can Lewis keep his head up under all this pressure?
Hamilton would never stop for someone else.
If Federer constantly travels...
...there's no way he can find time for his fans.
Music has always played the biggest role in her life.
It's tough to make your fans happy and your family.
Lewis Hamilton wins.